on garderait demain enfin un beau dessin
pour que je fasse une belle gang
oui elle n'oublie pas de signer c'est
quoi ta signature à dole à dole bonne
nuit la doll une résidence de trois mois
pour créer mettre en scène le spectacle
viennent 1913 elle permet à la compagnie
influence n2 bénéficier de l'équipement
du théâtre pour répéter avec le décor
donc ils peuvent améliorer le décor le
construire éventuellement ils peuvent
faire la création des lumières donc ils
ont toute une équipe de régisseur à leur
disposition on lui donne un outil de la
plateau un accès au plateau
ça c'est tout à fait essentiel pour
pouvoir créer et on nous donne la
possibilité aussi de rencontrer public
rencontrer le public et grâce à des
répétitions ouvertes aux spectateurs
mais aussi à d'autres actions comme la
réalisation dès samedi des inédits
permettant de présenter d'autres
spectacles un partenariat sur toute une
saison
il ya beaucoup d'autres actions qui vont
avoir lieu dont les samedis des inédits
qui sont aussi initiés par la compagnie
influent en scène qui vont permettre
aussi au public de découvrir des textes
inédits d'auteurs vivants
c'est vraiment une évolution tout au
long de la saison où les gens vont
finalement rencontrer les artistes sous
des angles différents
pendant la résidence des rencontres sont
organisées avec les lycées collèges ou
encore associations
objectif proposer au public des
tracteurs de cette création des retours
il ya des questions qu'ont fait un petit
bout de répète
comme ça dans la salle du lycée ça on
leur montre un petit bout comme ça du
travail ils nous posent des questions et
le fait qu'ils nous posent des questions
sur ce qu'ils viennent de voir ça me
fait réfléchir on ça nous permet de
creuser d'alimenter encore plus notre
travail de représentations auront lieu
le 20 novembre à 14h30 et à 18h45 au
théâtre espace coluche